screen ramp presents
I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Taylor Bradley
ten amazing movies that were almost
ruined by these decisions let's see what
they are
I hope NSYNC in Star Wars Episode two
was on this list almost ruined though
yeah almost a the key where they were
almost in it wait and sync this George
Lucas wanted to appeal to please like
what are we even talking about right now
okay
almost
[Music]
we closed casting is one of the most
important aspects of putting together a
film the filmmakers have to make sure
they have the right actors for each part
in order to establish the proper
emotional connection with the audience
this causes them to test several
thespians and some interesting what-ifs
could have drastically altered the
course of movie history here are screen
rants 10 movie castings that could have
changed popular films okay
Superman Christopher Reeve is still many
people's version of the perfect Superman
what about the Italian stallion
Sylvester Stallone turned down because
he was deemed too Italian he later found
out that Marlon Brando had casting
approval and was the one who turned
Stallone down I went on to criticize
Brando for his part of the decision
blasting him for using Superman as a
paycheck and nothing more still don't
love the character in mythology so he
certainly would have brought the passion
ever no it's not a lot of clones George
Lucas needed an older Anakin Skywalker
for Episode two one name he considered
was Hollywood superstar Leonardo
DiCaprio leo met with George Lucas to
discuss the part but turned it down
to work on gangs of new york with martin
scorsese yeah I'm a scab real for his
foresight gangs launched one of the most
successful actor director combos in this
century yeah hidden kristensen
floundered into obscurity after Star
Wars disappointed as talented as he is
even Leo may not have been able to save
Lucas no clunky dialogue no much prefer
watching him chase Oscars instead of
battle droids ah Jerry Maguire Tom who's
was born to play sports agent Jerry
Maguire directing him with a rockstar
persona befitting of his a-list status
but Cameron Crowe had originally
envisioned a different Tom head lighting
this comic Tom Hanks but the Oscar
winner was too old for the role by the
time Phil is ready to die making best
thing you'd thanks that's all can agree
it's almost impossible to see him as
Maguire after Cruz's terrific
performance my dream came on the phone
with Rod Tidwell just seems wrong Cruz
was perfect Casino Royale when the Bond
franchise moved on from Pierce Brosnan
the producers had to do an extensive
search to find the next double-o set
Daniel Craig landed the coveted role one
of the names strongly considered with
Sam Worthington starv James Cameron's
Avatar champion was a darker iteration
not too innocent
young charisma that defined the
character qualities Worthington has not
shown in his attempts to become an
action stone at least he'll always have
Jake Sully but Worthington was not right
for bond at all and Craig has become a
fan favorite
yeah his pretty toy story Tom Hanks and
Tim Allen are forever intertwine thanks
to the work together in the Toy Story
franchise but Hanks could have been
paired up with someone else
Pixar originally offered the Buzz
Lightyear role to comedian Billy Crystal
returned to death you regretted it after
seeing the film but in retrospect I just
worked on monsters crystals hyperactive
style may not have been the best fit for
the macho aloofness that carried buzz
through the first film steering helix
after funding from the start and not as
convincing for audiences crystal
eventually got an opportunity to work
with Pixar voicing the lovably zany Mike
was out yeah yeah that was perfect for
pulp fiction Jules Winnfield was made to
be played by samuel l.jackson but he
almost missed out on his career defining
role while Quentin Tarantino wrote
specifically for Jackson he was very
impressed by an audition from Paul
Calderon when Jackson heard this he flew
out to Los Angeles to meet with
Tarantino again and secured the park
ended up launching his career to
superstardom and earned an Oscar not so
it was a wise decision
Calderon got a small part of the film as
bartender Paul and he's so friendly and
welcoming it's hard to imagine him
reciting Ezekiel 25:17 as a cold-blooded
killer
collateral the role of besieged dragon
powers eventually went to Jamie Foxx and
heard the actor in Oscar nom but the
character evolved as the project went
along the screenwriter had wanted to use
Robert De Niro in an obvious callback to
his famous Travis Bickle character but
De Niro was deemed too old for the part
in a [ __ ] twist
none other than Adam Sandler met with
director Michael Mann where the director
decided to go with Fox to his credit
Sandler has turned in some dramatic
performances but he's not as versatile
an actress faster oh true Batman Begins
when rebooting Batman Christopher Nolan
tried out several actors for the Caped
Crusader and chose Christian Bale to
bring the property back to
respectability but one other name he
considered was Cillian Murphy would play
the Scarecrow in all three films of the
Dark Knight trilogy Murphy is a strong
actor but if you were Wayne that would
mean someone else would have to play
Jonathan crane since Murphy's turn as
the villain was well received and Bale
went on to putting a stamp on the
character we're happy things turned out
the way they did the Bale voice has gone
down and ledge
check out America the First Avenger
nowadays it's hard to envision anyone
other than Chris Evans as the
star-spangled man but the office star
joins in ski was in the running for the
role he exemplifies the same optimistic
gung-ho attitude is so vital for the
character you want to be great
interesting to see if he had the action
chops to pull it off any higher yeah but
rigging powers yeah Johnny Storm into
Fantastic Four flicks even if those
weren't great movies they still show it
Adams had what it took to play a
likeable superhero back to the country
Michael J Fox is inseparable from Marty
McFly but scheduling conflicts initially
caused him to skip out on the film
Robert Zemeckis originally went with
Eric Stoltz Regatta principal
photography got a few days in he
realized something wasn't right and Fox
worked a deal to take on the role
instead Zemeckis felt Stoltz wasn't
funny enough to play Marty and to his
credit the actor agreed with the
decision the rest is history
and Fox a sense of humor and comedic
chops made him an instant classic with
movies - yeah when else we'd rather see
introducing the world to Johnny be good
so what do you think of our list
which near casting decisions would you
have liked to see happen sound off in
the comments section below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one
[Music]
those from Screen Rant people check out
their channel they do a lot of videos
like that um Stallone as supermo my god
that would have been atrocious I would
have been tick like Stallone back in the
70s great actors Rocky he was fantastic
a Superman though the voice is too like
his voice is way too specific it would
have come across comical yeah no one
would have been able to no good well
Betty was to italian louis that's more
than his look no yeah it's is four it's
gonna bring a does yeah but he could
pull off the body sure right but there's
way more old so many people in Hollywood
short - yeah I am mad that they even
considered him for the role okay let's
calm
okay I'm sorry take some breaths please
okay I'm really also really proud of
Marlon Brando for being the one to make
that decision - yeah yeah brilliant he's
known for making amazing acting choices
here in an acting school forever like
yeah he's also um you know like people
did criticize him for just doing it for
the Paycheck people still really liked
him as that character yeah jor-el yeah
so that's my little point yeah DiCaprio
almost cast as Anakin Skywalker thank
God
DiCaprio did not do that I mean I'm glad
he did Gangs of New York instead yeah
but I also feel like even seeing the
poster with him photoshopped on as that
thing looked a little bit b-movie yeah
totally didn't it seem a little bit more
like cheapened yeah and I'm not saying
Leonardo DiCaprio cheapens movies cuz he
definitely doesn't he's been in a lot of
really amazing movies recently but him
younger like that I think it just would
have been it would not have fit well for
Episode two
yeah totally especially because George
Lucas manages to make great actors not
look so great right like his direction
for acting is horrible
he can't be the only time he did an okay
job with Star Wars the first one now the
prequels horrible direction on acting
it's just like Natalie Portman is one of
the best actresses of all she's amazing
she sucks in Star Wars movies awesome
great and it's not I don't think it's
the actors fault a lot of the time I
feel like a lot of it comes down to
George Lucas's direction so I feel like
DiCaprio still wouldn't have saved the
movie and I thought it was a great
decision that he went with Scorsese cuz
he is it's like who would you rather
work with a legendary director who's
known for bringing out amazing
performances and actors and establishing
that relationship which could hopefully
lead to something long-term for an Oscar
yeah or an Oscar for me see see revenant
he was amazing
we'll see yeah I hope he gets the Oscar
for revenant DiCaprio I've always
respected his decisions Tom Hanks Tom
Hanks and Jerry Maguire can't see it no
I think he would have been a little bit
I mean I love Tom Hanks I loved him in
every single movie that I've ever seen
him in he's so lovable he's like so
charming but I just think Tom Cruise
he's the perfect fit for Jerry Maguire
the young sexy sports
AJ you know like he was perfect the
charisma that he that like not to say
Tom Hanks doesn't have charisma that he
couldn't pull off the role I just feel
like Tom Cruise hands-down would have
been the best choice right which they
obviously agreed with you thank you
Cameron Crowe for agreeing with me
Casino Royale sooner oh yeah yes Sam
Worthington this video I felt like could
have given him a little credit for
pulling off bond because he was in
Terminator Salvation which was an action
role as well he did avatar which
required action and he also did um the
sabotage which required action so I feel
like he could do action he doesn't have
enough pain in his eyes yeah there's
there's a lack of intensity and I think
bond needs to have a little bit of pain
yeah especially for the bond they were
going for yeah yeah I don't think the
performance was powerful and Daniel
Craig's proved himself to be a much more
reliable accurate ooh yeah plus Daniel
Craig when that scene where he's like
naked and he's getting his balls hit
trust me for Annika and I we have done
their swing the rope hit the balls oh
this is weird you won't watch us
something Billy Crystal for Buzz
Lightyear yeah I mean okay when you hear
woody you hear Tom Hanks and I love that
yes can hear buzz lie here though I hear
only Buzz Lightyear yeah I'm not aware
I'm listening to Tim Allen yeah moment
you know with Billy Crystal like I
forgot it Mike's without Wazowski yeah
that's perfect for Billy Crystal and
because it seems like this is a Billy
Crystal kind of character right whereas
Buzz Lightyear kinda wouldn't have
matched the Billy Crystal persona no and
I think they nailed it when they said
the masculinity of his voice it needs to
be so like booming and he has like
himself very seriously because he
doesn't think he's a toy and I think
that's one of the whole things that
sells that relationship that he has to
take himself so seriously and I just
feel like Billy Crystal would struggle
with that yeah it's funny how the wrong
casting decision can go a long way
oh yeah casting is like the number one
most important thing about making them
that's why actors are treated like
royalty and why they're better than us
normal people
[Music]
actually what's interesting about pulp
fiction I thought they're gonna point
out something else John Travolta's role
that was his comeback role yeah that was
pulp fiction people loved him in it
however Daniel day-lewis was that was
one of the few roles that he was
actively trying to get real Tarantino
set was saying no I want your bolts in
Travolta was perfect in the role yeah I
don't know I feel like Daniel day-lewis
cuz cuz Pulp Fiction with John
Travolta's character is kind of more
like he's more laid back and like a
hanging out guys I like the most intent
there's intense scenes with him but he's
not like the most intense dude and no no
Daniel day-lewis I he's a great actor
for like the super powerful performance
for him Lincoln like Abraham Lincoln
black yeah well periodic performances
biopics and stuff but something about
his personality I don't feel like would
have nest as well with Paul fiction
however deo day-lewis can also do
anything yes but I think Travolta was
great and now we have a wonderful gift
because of him yeah I've ever seen that
those always like holding the jacket and
he's looking around lost know what
collateral that is one of the best
movies I've ever seen I don't know it's
in my top 10 but if I had a top 20 I'd
probably put it there Jamie Foxx was
wonderful in the role they were saying
they were thinking of DeNiro yes we've
been a totally different movie I don't
think it would have been bad I just
think it would have been very different
part of the great dynamic of those
characters was the fact that Tom Cruise
you know he looked aged he would he had
gray hair in that movie the weight of
his facial hair they made him look a lot
older and the fact that Jamie Foxx was
younger treats him a more interesting
dynamic
if DeNiro looked around the same age or
older it just wouldn't have been as
powerful for some reason the fact that
Jamie Foxx was young shows that he's
less experienced in life and he you know
he has his ambitions to make a [ __ ]
limousine business more night yeah it
makes more sense for the character makes
more of an innocence behind the role
right whereas opposed to DeNiro were
used to seeing and be a tough guy and
stuff right that um I feel like Jamie
Foxx was perfect because he was known
for his comedy way more at the time and
it was a good career move for him it was
a hot one was smarted I think that year
he I think that was a year he also won
for Ray I think
rayon that really shame here yeah
alright the Batman flip here's here's my
thing
um I'm not a huge Christian Bale fan in
general in general really he takes
himself so seriously and you can tell
but this was their other choice for
Batman like I would rather see Christian
Bale than this guy who don't see him as
Batman and if it was between him and
Christian Bale I'd probably still think
Killian Killian Murphy also like he look
he doesn't look American nobody looks
very European yeah he doesn't look
American and that Bruce Wayne's very
American okay I have a joke for you yes
if you're a Russian on the way to the
bathroom
what are you once you get there Russian
on the way to the bathroom yeah what
European you're a peon yes my favorite
job and I thought my jokes were bad
after America I think uh the guy from
the office would have been great John
Krasinski yeah I think he would have
been cool too
I don't see any problem with it however
though Captain America like [ __ ]
Chris Evans has like the all-american
look yes sexy look but John Krasinski I
felt like would have been an interesting
choice I feel like he would have brought
a unique charm to the role I think so
too because in the first Captain America
I thought the film was kind of bland
overall like I wasn't a big fan of the
first Captain America not bland bland is
the wrong choice of words but Captain
America himself I felt lacked in
personality and I think he would have
brought that and I feel like you would
have brought that a granite Chris Evans
has proven that he's a grey Captain
America in later films for me like
Winter Soldier Avengers yeah I think
he's great in those but for the first
Captain America I don't know if like
John like they did such a great job with
casting comedic actor Paul Rudd
yeah and man I feel like John Krasinski
could have brought something really neat
as well yeah totally so that would have
been a choice of word I've been upset
about that what excited me listen guys
um this video is done if you're new to
the channel subscribe to the real
rejects Taylor Bradley instagram.com
slash Kayla Bradley 9
one she was born in the year 1991 the
year of the Jewish dragon I don't think
that's a thing
yes it's is it really the Jewish dragon
the one that flies higher high that
breathes fire my gosh you almost had me
first
I'm just like I am my dragon sounds like
Al Pacino you're coughing up a hairball
an italiano Americana webseries on her
channel check it out season 1 episodes
have been released so um all the way
through episode 8 and one of the new
episodes come out every Sunday at 7:00
good good
and Taylor Bradley says there's no
nudity in it so but there are bikinis
how often uh like every four episodes
probably to know if you want more views
and we're in a besom war bikini what's
that girl's name
Emily Emily what Jordan alright guys if
you want to see this girl in a bikini
check out her show she's gorgeous and
she's really funny
ya know those are reasons to videos done
to her oh my goodness